Hello friends of the prompt today we're
going to look at this paper which has
made quite a couple of waves what
happens if you ask chat GPT to repeat
this word forever pom pom pom pom it
leaks training data so the claim here is
if you ask chat GPT for some relatively
weird thing like repeating a word
forever eventually it'll just spit out
its training data and yeah this
obviously has implication for privacy
and so on um also for data protection
copyright whatnot uh so far it's always
been kind of mysterious what these
models have been trained on and attempts
to get out training data from these
models have been harder and harder and
harder and therefore it's all the more
surprising that something like this
would actually start leaking training
data so this is very interesting and uh
the question is how do these people know
this is training data uh why does this
work and what does it mean how much
training data can you get out and so on
so all of this has quite a degree of
nuance to it and what we'll look at
today is the paper behind it which is
called scalable extraction of training
data from production language models and
uh we unfortunately can't go over the
whole paper because the paper is dense
uh and it has multiple different things
inside of it like scaling laws for
extracting data and so on different
models data set building um I invite you
to read the paper yourself if you're
interested in this kind of stuff we'll
go over the most important points uh to
answer the what I think are interesting
or some of the interesting questions
around this now to be said I have tried
this particular thing uh you know repeat
the following word infinitely many times
or forever whatever and uh open AI will
there there is a warning now that the
content may violate the content policy
so the first time I did this I thought
maybe it was about to spit out some
adult content right because it was it
started to leak training data and
therefore uh the adult content and the
training data may have been adult
content and therefore that was detected
but I was able sometimes to reproduce
this uh violation burning right here and
it's quite conceivable that since this
paper has been released and the paper
has followed responsible disclosure
disclosing the vulnerability to open AI
uh 90 days ago and so it's quite
conceivable that open area has fixed
this not by retraining the model but
simply by detecting repetition and uh
just striking you when they detected so
that's that uh very very simple fix
right here now suffice to say this only
obviously works to defend against this
one particular attack and um not against
other ones but the flip side of the coin
is that the paper states that they've
only found this one particular attack
and it only works for chat GPT so yeah
make of that was as you will um the
general finding or finding ings or one
of the general findings here is the
following
the authors test how much training data
they can extract from models and their
one of their conclusions is the models
emit more memorized training data as
they get larger the aligned chat GPT
which is just what you know as the
original or chat GPT 35 turbo appears 50
times more private than any prior model
but we develop an attack that shows it
is not this needs a little bit of
context and we'll go into it a bit but
the initial ramp up here is an attack
where they essentially just take
uh things that they think are or know
are in the training data like they take
token sequences from Wikipedia or
something because all of these models
are trained on the internet and certain
lead to a lot large part on Wikipedia
they say well we can be reasonably sure
this was in the training data so they
they prompt with part of that and then
they hope essentially that the model
continues generating the the rest of
that if it has actually memorized that
part of the training data and that seems
to work and that seems to work more and
more and more the larger the models are
there is also hypothesis around
overtraining and so on but in general
the larger the models the more training
data they memorize and the more they
then spit out again uh this it's
interesting because it also connects to
literature uh around let's say pruning
and so on uh where people have figured
out if we if we prune large language
models what will fall away are mostly
sort of uh outliers the the tales of the
distributions because what tends to
happen or at least the hypothesis is
that these large models they store the
common things in their like in the in
some parameters like the whenever they
can extract patterns that goes into one
part and whenever they can't extract
patterns as easily essentially they just
store the stuff verbatim and obviously
the larger models they have a lot more
space to store this kind of stuff
verbatim somewhere and maybe that's the
part that's spat out here so it would be
interesting to see that whether the
parts of the training data that are spat
out are more of the outlier type more of
the tail end type of text rather than
sort of the comma type or whether yeah
it it would just be interesting to
analyze that a little bit more the paper
does it a little bit but sorry go on
going on from the tangent uh you can see
that the larger the models get the more
they're prone to just spitting out
training data when being prompted with
part of it uh or what was likely part of
it chat GPT not at all right the bar is
barely noticeable on this bar chart
right here seem chat gbt seems to defy
this Rule and that the author's
hypothesize is largely due to it being
aligned meaning that it's trained as a
chat model and an and an assistant and
not just as a I continue your string
model and and it does not do that
however with their new attack right with
their repeat this word forever it
actually spits out a ton more of
training data uh than and if you assume
that instruct GPT and chat gbt are uh
approximately derived from the same base
model and therefore are of the same size
then you can see that with this attack
and due to the alignment and maybe also
due to overtraining chat GPT actually
leaks a lot more training data uh than
the base model or than instruct GPT
which has been tuned on the same base
model so lots of questions out here uh
but uh lots of interesting answers
coming up as well uh small side question
that you may have right here is well
what happens if you apply the attack to
these models over here and the answer is
it does not work well um it it really
seems to work for chat gbt for some
reason they go and they Define some
things so the whole paper is framed in
this jua position between what they call
extractable memorization and what we'll
later call discoverable memorization I
think that's what they call it
yes extractable memorization is anything
that you can extract so we they call an
example from the training data extracta
memorized if an adversary without access
to X can construct a prompt that makes
the model produce X so if it is possible
to find a prompt that
produces the a training data sample we
call that extracta memorized I.E there
is a prompt that allows me to extract
that particular
string so that that's uh not always the
the case there could be things that are
memorized some way but there's no prompt
that could get them out right because
prompts are discrete things um or or
there could be it could be just not
memorized now there is a bit of a um
Shady part here not shady but uh one can
also reasonably say that sometimes the
paper the
paper talks about extractable
memorization
um but by just saying here that an
attacker can construct a prompt with
reasonable effort like that that it is
efficiently possible to construct such a
prompt because you could just enumerate
all prompts and uh then your set of
extracta memorized things would maybe be
different than what you can reasonably
do so the paper is not clear on which
exact definition it's working on but
it's not that
important the questions that arise is uh
so they say prior work was primarily
hindered by two challenges and I think
I've made even a video on prior work
where uh some of the same authors from
here were able to extract personal
information from
gpt2 which turned out to be part of the
training data it was actually real
personal information now one has to say
that like the address and the phone
number they got out was a business phone
number that was plasted onto you know
lots and lots and lots of that that
business had automatically generated
websites for their listings and on every
single website that address and phone
number was you know listed at the bottom
and therefore it's reasonable to say
that a language model would actually
remember that and spit it out quite
easily but that was the paper already
then they say that work was hindered by
two challenges how should we design
prompts that best elicit memorization
and how do we test whether an attack
worked like whether the models output in
is in the training data or not with
respect to the previous work uh the
design of prompts was essentially just
done by what I said before hey let's go
to the Internet let's
just grab some text from there and those
are our prompts because gpd2 was
probably trained on a large part of the
internet and therefore those things are
probably part of the training data and
on the other hand testing whether an
attack worked is has been done by
manually checking whether these strings
can be found with a Google search
essentially assuming that you know if
the training set is actually from the
internet a Google search will find it
now as we know uh probably open AI
models are trained on more than just
publicly accessible internet especially
also some uh let's Loosely say allegedly
pirated stuff and maybe that you
wouldn't be able to find as easily with
Google um and therefore who knows and
that's what this paper asks as well
these prior work only verifiably
recovers a tiny fraction of GPT 2's
training set and they say the authors
acknowledge that this is likely a loose
lower bound and they could not produce a
tighter estimate due to the timec
consuming manual verification procedure
that their attack
involves and they say the flip side to
this is how about we try to get an upper
bound on what is
memorized an upper bound uh can we can
we get one if we know the training set
if we we know the training data set then
what we can do is we can actually go to
the training data set we can get a piece
of text from the training data set let's
say that's the piece of text we can
split it up right and we make the left
part The Prompt and we see whether the
right part the continuation is produced
by the model and they call that
discoverable
memorization so if we take an example
prompt followed by uh continuation from
the training set we say that X is
discover memorized if inputting that
prompt gives you that
continuation and they claim they say
here previous work has shown that llms
discover memorize roughly 1% of their
training data set and that means there
is a huge gap between the lower bounds
that we saw before on extractable
memorization and the upper bounds that
assume full access ACC to the training
set the question is why they say there
are two possible explanations for The
observed Gap first of all prompting
models with training data leads to
orders of magnitude more training data
regurgitation essentially saying hey if
I prompt with something that I know is
in the training data I'm just going to
get that much more output than if I
prompt something with something that's
on the randomly on the internet secondly
they say alternatively perhaps existing
extraction attacks already make model
regurgitate large amount of training
data but prior work was not able to
verify that the model outputs were
training data essentially saying hey if
you have to go to Google every time you
search um and you check whether you can
find stuff or not you know maybe that's
not enough maybe that actually does not
you know you don't find stuff or you
don't look correctly and so on and
therefore you might might actually have
missed that a lot of these things were
somewhere on the internet and you just
didn't find them they say as we will
show the latter explanation is mostly
the correct one existing extraction
attacks are actually a lot more stress
successful at recovering training data
than what prior work indicates soent and
that makes sense right given that the
method of constructing prompts for the
extractable memorization is I go to
Wikipedia and I take like some kind of
tokens from there or I go to other
popular websites it's so likely that
that's actually part of the training
data of these large models that there's
not probably not too much of a
difference uh between doing that and
taking actual prompts from the training
data so therefore it's unlikely that
that is making such a big difference and
therefore number two here is probably
the more likely culprit
now this part of the paper is it's built
up by a lot but essentially what it
boils down to is saying the other people
or I guess it's the same people didn't
really do a good job Google searching so
we make a giant data set out of a lot of
the data sets that are around and we
plop them together and we put them into
a data structure where we can
efficiently check for membership
like all of this build up and that's why
I say it's a lot of stuff in a single
paper but all of this buildup so far
with o upper bound lower bound different
possibilities and so on actually just
comes down to how about we make a better
Google search like a better search for
whether something is somewhere on the
Internet or not which is obviously
different from a search a membership
attack just gives you a yes or no but
it all boil down to this hey we make a
giant data set and uh which we call Ox
something where is it they describe it
somewhere we make a giant data set out
of a ton of stuff that's on the internet
and uh we check whether stuff is in
there that that's that that's what they
do they first do that for open source
models where they have all the training
data so they don't need to do the giant
one so they research there and that's a
different part of the paper and this
part of the paper here what the main
goal is is to derive scaling laws for
memorization so again part of the same
paper and part of the same paper is also
going to be that chat GPT attack from
later so this could have easily been I
guess three different papers but we'll
slowly go through the main points so in
this section right here they say okay
let's start with open- Source models
where we have full access to the
training data and let's actually look
how
memorization uh in in different things
is dependent on the size of the model
and can we
extrapolate you know how much training
data we could in total get out of each
model if we were to do this procedure of
prompting prompting prompting prompting
forever
okay so the results are in this table
you can see that as the models get
bigger that the arrow isn't necessarily
bigger they're grouped by type of model
but as the models get bigger they
memorize more and more so you get more
unique 50 gs out of these models as the
parameter counts go up and um yeah it's
not it's different from model to model
so different
model types of the same size have quite
different uh memorization capabilities
so for example the red pajama 7B model
and the pytha 7B model they memorize
constant Factor differences from each
other but the general Trend that the
higher the uh the higher the parameter
count the more training data is exactly
remembered is not uh broken here or is
common and that allows them to derive
these scaling laws from measuring how
many 50 grams they can extract or how
many training data samples they can
extract uh by trying a few times they
can then
extrapolate way out and say well if we
did this forever how much would be our
upper bound or where would we converge
to so then here in this table they're
able to give an an estimate of how many
50 gs they could potentially get out of
these
models and that investigation is
important because it allows us to then
also estimate how much we would get out
of chat GPT uh if these scaling laws
actually hold similarly
there I'm going to jump a bit ahead here
and there is a here which I find quite
interesting which is called discoverable
memorization versus extractable
memorization now previously they have
talked about lower bound and upper bound
but the astute observers among you may
have noticed that that's not actually
true the what they called discoverable
memorization up here isn't really an
upper bound on you know on
uh isn't really an upper bound on the
amount of memorized stuff because
obviously if you take a training examp
something that's actually from the
training set and you split it up like
this then yes it makes a lot of sense
that for this given X the text
immediately in front of it in the
training set would be the best prompt
especially if the model is trained with
a language model objective would be the
best prompt to elicit that output right
that's completely reasonable to say
however it's not a guarantee it could be
that while this prompt doesn't produce
that output there could be some other
prompt somewhere that in fact does
produce this output and therefore
extractable memorization like actually
true extractable memorization as defined
up here without without any requirements
on uh how efficient one needs to
construct these
is the true upper bound right the the
mathematical upper bound um whereas the
discoverable memorization is just a a
really good juristic that will probably
get you a good accurate estimation uh if
you have access to the training data set
and that's captured in this table down
here so they do find which is which is
interesting okay uh they do find that
most of the data in the training sets is
neither uh discoverable nor extractable
that's fair right however there is there
is um there's obviously data that's both
discoverable and extractable but there
is also a larger part only discoverable
only so this is about double the size of
discoverable and extractable so
everything that's discoverable splits up
into about 1/3 that's also
extractable uh so that
means 2/3 here you cannot get by simply
you know going through uh prompts that
you find on the internet somewhere you
actually need the exact one from the
training data set now again given that
all these training data sets are kind of
constructed from the Internet is it just
that uh they didn't try
enough I don't so they they say uh they
also talk about this here um this
surprisingly despite generating several
hundred billion tokens only 35% of the
discoverable memorized examples were
also extractable while this is orders of
magnitude larger than have previously
been believed it is still not most or
even all of the data that is known to be
memorized
that's true and more surprisingly they
also have a quite sizable portion here
that is extractable but not discoverable
they say here we also uncover an
additional 11% memorized sequences via
our extractable memorization attacks
that were not discover
memorized which which is
uh also interesting they investigate
this a little bit saying we see that
highly duplicated sequences are also
both easier to extract and discover we
make four observations from this data
first it is somewhat surprising that a
simple attack that just samples from the
model is sufficient to recover a large
fraction of all known memorized training
data second there's room for improving
current extraction attacks third
measuring discoverable memorization is a
useful and reasonably tight
characterization of data that can
actually be extracted by an adversary
and for fourth there is also room to
discover to improve discoverable
memorization but if we know the training
data uh we still don't get all that's
memorized which is yeah
surprising yeah there there still exist
data that is extracta memorized but not
discovered in the way that they did
which is
interesting so I just thought that was
interesting again another section of the
paper that is just interesting uh but
where are we on our path to extracting
stuff from chat gbt by repeating a lot
of times uh extracting data from semi
closed models there we go they Define
semi closed models as those that have
publicly available downloadable
parameters but whose training data sets
and training algorithms are not known
which uh in my mind does not like that
definition doesn't
really it's meaningless because now here
they have a table where GPT 35 instruct
is in and uh sure they can only spend
less money on it uh they can only spend
$200 on it instead of doing like
billions and billions of samplings But
ultimately they don't really use the
fact that the weights are publicly
available for these other models at
least not as far as I
have seen like they don't necessarily
inspect them uh they don't necessarily
back propop through them or anything
like this
so yeah one could have just called this
like closed models or where we don't
know the training data and for this it's
really important that they construct
their giant data set out of other like
just combining other giant data sets
right here and then do that efficient
membership
inference uh that that I've talked about
all right results all models emit
memorized training data that's already
interesting the worst offender is 3pt
GPT 3.5 turbo instruct that's not chat
GPT that's the instruct version of GPT
35 where
0.852 per of generated tokens are part
of 50 token sequences found a verb ATM
in their giant data
set okay so that's already interesting
then they go to chat
GPT so they say chat GPT isn't a
traditional language model it's
actually aligned to behave better
according to human preferences which
allows it to be deployed as a
conversational agent that is designed to
specifically interact with users via a
dialogue
interface the alignment found in
language models such as chat GPT creates
additional challenges for designing a
successful extraction attacks and you
may notice that the instruct model is
also not just a pure language model
however they say it's probably been
fine-tuned less away from the language
model objective than something like chat
GPT which is why their extraction attack
still works there and doesn't work for
chat GPT specifically here they say uh
they try to adapt
their their prompt and then continuation
to jat gbt where they say you know write
the following words and then continue
from there so again they input uh string
they found on the
internet and then they ask chat gbt to
say repeat this and then continue from
there and very often that model just
kind of refuses to do so or just kind of
stops after it or something like this um
because it's not a pure language model
it's actually a chat model and that
really throws a throws a stick into
their gears uh when they try to to do
their
extraction so what do what do they do by
the way this particular string they show
here uh this later they they know that
this is a memorized string so even with
strings that they know are memorized it
does not work you can't like uh ask chat
GPD for training data now that could be
because it's trained as a chat model but
it could also be because open air has
specifically also introduced slipped in
a few training examples where they
discouraged it from from doing this uh
pure language modeling
objective right to to actually halt
people from extracting training
data so they say the Baseline attack
isn't good but yeah um we repeat the
above experiments uh several thousand
times with different prompts out of
these tokens just 0.02% of tokens are
part of 50 token sequences that is
copied from our data set and
um comparable GPT 35 turbo instruct
model where
0.85% of emitted tokens are part of
memorized sequence from this we might
conclude that the alignment procedure
has correctly prevented the model from
emitting training data but as we'll soon
see this is
incorrect they come up with this new
attack and that's the one you saw in the
Tweet so that
is if they just ask the model to repeat
word forever it's they call it it
diverges it kind of escapes out of the
alignment trainings and falls back to
the original language modeling
objective once the model diverges its
Generations are often nonsensical but a
small fraction of generations diverge to
memorizationscripture
like is it really about the question is
is it really about this particular task
of repeating the one word over and over
and over or is it just that you bring it
so far out of
distribution that the alignment training
isn't relevant what I mean by that
is if you have a base language model and
you input something and it could it
could go in many directions right it has
a probability distribution over
continuations from that
input now what alignment training does
at least the way I understand it it's is
kind of calls away some of that where
you say I'm going to delete away all of
the possible distribution space of
continuations and I'm going to leave
only the ones that uh I deem align with
human preferences right but this isn't
necessarily uniform okay this training
only applies to or largely applies to
starting points that are also
interesting and relevant for this kind
of things because the training data for
this is these assistant conversations
and therefore the points in the like if
any of these points represents an
initial input an initial prompt to the
model only of those and of these points
you always have the different directions
and so on I would think think that the
fine-tuning
training doesn't affect all of these
points equally right but it is probably
heavily biased towards the initial
points that already represent some sort
of agent or assistant interaction and
other points that just represent like
some garbage text that you know they
would never appear in that fine-tuning
data set and therefore their
continuation space let's call it would
largely remain unaffected by the
fine-tuning training so the fine-tuning
training probably doesn't affect the
entire input space equally and uniformly
and therefore one could argue that the
sense behind an attack like this is
simply to bring the model out of
this assistant conversation mode and
into territory of the input space where
uh the fine-tuning did not apply as much
or did not force or did not reshape the
distribution space as much the
continuation space and therefore it's
much more like a language model again
specifically also if you go to the far
outsides you're probably in that long
tail regime and there probably again if
you believe prior work there
memorization is much more common than
actual pattern learning right so the
effects could overlap right here however
there is also another aspect here namely
that you would then guess that any uh
input that drives the model somewhere uh
where it hasn't been um that drives the
model somewhere off distribution would
do that and there is an interesting
point uh to this particular attack
namely
namely where is it
saying
here the only words that lead to
memorization are the words that are
single token in the vocabulary asking
the model to repeat multi- token words
so you know if you have text you
tokenize it and so this would be a token
this would be a token but for example
finding might be two tokens like find
and then in might be another token so
they say only single token words cause
the model to do this if you ask the
model to repeat multi- token words it
never causes the model to emit training
data because it never causes the model
to diverge in fact there are words that
are way more effective than other words
in doing this so whereas one side of the
argument says all you have to do is
bring the model you know far away from
anything in distribution of the
fine-tuning pre-training and it will
sort of start producing or fall back to
language modeling the other side of the
argument
is there seems to be something very
particular about
repeating a single token over and over
again and even more so than it is a
single token because multi toen
repetitions would also very probably get
it out of the like it's also out of
distribution but even in single token it
matters which
token and it's not like that you know it
it's not like uh that the word company
just makes it diverge more often no you
also as far as I understand the paper
get more diverse set of training data
that's then output uh when you use the
better tokens so that lends credibility
to that there's actually something about
this particular thing and not just the
fact that you get it of
distribution yeah it's it's very very
interesting they they do a bit of
analysis on what they find right here
they find various things um URLs in
identifiable information code uh
research papers boilerplate text
obviously stuff that's highly memorized
in fact their longest sequence here the
one with over 4,000 characters was a
websites terms of service agreement
which is probably a highly replicated
piece of text um that you know
um so yeah highly repeated stuff is more
likely to be memorized but we already
knew this
largely um
yeah what
else the last part here is where they
investigate
can we actually figure out a metric uh
that allows us to tell whether something
was in the training data set so now that
they have done a large
investigation um into that they can say
or they claim that this quantity right
here the likelihood ratio so you divide
the perplexity that the llm gives you by
the perplexity that the text has under a
standard text compression the zip text
compression algorithm and and if that
likelihood ratio is
high uh
low I'm not exactly sure which direction
but that will determine that will
determine um so if the if the llm
compresses
text equally well to or or better than
the uh um
the ZB like a general text compression
algorithm is probably part of the
training data if it doesn't compress it
well compared to standard text
compression it's probably
not maybe I don't know if that that's
the the right way around in any case
this
number I don't can't tell you whether
it's high or or low but this number is
they say is very the most effective at
predicting memorization in Prior work
and in our evaluation we find it is
highly accurate in our setting as well
and by highly accurate they mean I
believe 15 to 30% or something like this
above 30% yeah uh
so which is interesting um because it
even discourages people you know
companies like open AI from giving you
access to the Token likelihoods right
because from the token likelihoods of
something you could compute its
perplexity uh and therefore you could
compute a membership uh inference given
this this number right here and and so
knowing this the companies that offer
such models will probably less and less
give you access to these types of
quantities given that you can do more
and more with them as research
progresses
uh they go back to chat GPT
and they say you know our attack is not
generalizable to other models but now
that we do have a set of things that we
know are part of chat gpt's training set
because they've just extracted that with
their poem poem po poem thing we can
take these samples that are known to be
in the model's training set and split
them into prefix and suffix and the
measure a discoverable memorization so
they can go back to what they previously
called upper bound methods they can take
the the things that they know are part
of the training set right uh split them
up and see of whether if they input the
prefix as a prompt they can get out the
suffix and it turns out no you cannot uh
when we prompt the model in this way
gp35 turbo completes the corresponding
50 token suffix in just 3.5% of the
cases that means over 90% of the time
the model fails to emit the memorized
output that we know to be memorized
which means it's extremely difficult to
uh it's extremely difficult to test very
aligned or overtrained or whichever one
is responsible models for membership uh
for discoverable memorization so even if
you know something is remembered you
won't get it out of there with high
likelihood yeah that's essentially it
they have a hypothesis on why repeating
a single token is
unstable
um they say we do not have an
explanation for why this is true but the
effect is significant and easily
repeatable and it could be due to the
fact that word repetition May simulate
the end of text token uh because you
train these models by you know putting
document when it's over you don't you
don't stop you actually put an end of
text and you put the next document there
that's how you train language models
nowadays because you want to make use of
optimal packing for computation and what
they show is that as you repeat uh
single tokens
here the axis here measures how close
the last layers attention I think query
vectors are to the query vectors of the
beginning of sentence token and that's
in a I believe in a llama model yes in a
llama model so llama models they have
beginning of sentence tokens so at the
beginning of each sample they do Vos
right they do a token like this and then
there you there you go and
that BOS token that emits obviously some
query vectors and what they can show is
that as they repeat these single uh
tokens the query query vectors of that
last repeated token more and more or
similar to the query vectors of that
beginning of sentence token so from the
attention computation it may look to
these models as if there was a beginning
of text like as if a new sample starts
and then it's just kind of language
modeling for them at that point now
whether that's true or not I'm not I'm
not sure because obviously it would make
sense because then there is a BOS token
and then there is no like usually the
the messages are then like
system colon like or things like this so
one would expect that maybe that these
tokens would then be uh output by like
if it's actually saying you know here
one training sample is
over given that it's been fine-tuned
exclusively on like assistant things uh
it may output one of these but maybe
it's been fine- tuned on a mix and
therefore it might not in any case this
is fairly interesting uh but I don't
know exactly what it
means it could it could just be like a
second AR effect of whatever is
responsible for making this happen uh
but it is interesting that they have
investigated and it does seem that the
effect is quite pronounced in that if
you just do language
modeling almost no token has equal query
query uh vectors as the BOS token and if
you repeat that one token over and over
it actually does and the question is
obviously if you can get it to diverge
in other ways this happen too or is this
really the property of that repetition
is the repetition in some way relevant
what I can imagine is that if you repeat
the same token over and over and over
again right you kind of have at the
lowest layer you always have the same
embedding Vector for the single token
right which would result in the same uh
query Vector now obviously the position
and codings are different but you would
have
like very so you have whereas usually
you have like a vector like this this
and one like this and one like this and
one like this and they do their query
and so on you'd essentially just have
the same like this and this and this and
this and you all add them together
obviously and then you do a soft Max and
uh so because you add them all together
it's like super duper Amplified in a
single Direction which might just
overload the numerics of the system a
little bit like it it could totally be
that uh because everything's the same
for each token you just kind of overload
the numerics you just your space becomes
extremely low rank and uh because you
only have the one thing and that just
kind of smashes all of the the
normalizations and the uh computations
and so on but no no guarantees here that
that is of any of any truth just find it
interesting and I think probably some
more invest instigation is warranted
here and probably a lot of people are
already doing some more
investigation now that was my overview
of this paper there's a lot more in this
paper than I have not covered yet uh
even though I feel I've covered a lot of
the paper but definitely give it a read
if you're more interested and yeah uh
lots of interesting stuff coming out and
if you discover some other uh attack
here maybe you know don't tell open AI I
know this goes against responsible
disclosure
but
ah all right that was it for me thank
you for listening bye-bye